Beyonce and jay-z are going on tour
together again
how Tiffany Haddish his Oscar running
with Meryl Streep really went down plus
Olympic figure skater out of rip pond
finally meets his celeb crush hello
everybody
award season is over but we got some
really fun leftovers from Sunday's
Oscars for you in just a bit but first
Beyonce and jay-z are going on tour
together that's right I can confirm the
Carters will hit the road again this
summer a follow-up to their epic on the
run joint tour they did back in 2014
which by the way generated over 100
million dollars my source adds tickets
are expected to go on sale next week I
always say to have some money saved up
in case Beyonce announces a surprise
tour did I do that no am I still going
yes but first Queen B has her sights set
on Coachella she recently gave fans a
peek at her rehearsals and her abs
clearly the mother of three is putting
in some work since giving birth to twins
Sir Andrew me and to help her get
Coachella body ready
she's also revealed she's back on the
vegan diet and encouraged fans to join
her so guess what I'm going vegan now I
don't judge me my wristbands for the
festival came in the mail yesterday and
I don't think you're ready for this
jelly Coachella so we're gonna do it
starting Thursday 22 days vegan follow
along with me on my instagram at d
direct oh and also let me know if you
guys have any tips tricks recipes I need
all the help I can get but again
starting Thursday because I need two
days to eat all the meat and cheese
folks alright yesterday I told you guys
about beyoncé and jay-z's exclusive
Oscars party for mary j blige
we're told the guest list only included
a hundred and fifty people but someone
who did score an invite miss Tiffany
Haddish Tiffany has not tweeted or said
anything about what went down at the
party
why but we are learning more about
Tiffany meeting Meryl Streep on the
Oscars red carpet thankfully Jimmy
Kimmel's cameras captured it all
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
Melrose
[Applause]
Tiffiny literally booked it she was like
I'm not gonna miss my chance to meet
Meryl and it paid off
we caught up with a girl ship star at
the Vanity Fair Oscar party where she
was still on cloud nine daughters are
here so they should realize that family
has joined the party hello
I'm a sister named Meryl Streep and
Tiffany Haddish in the same project like
she said anything can happen
just ask Olympic skater Adam rip on and
I'm not talking about him taking home a
bronze medal at the Winter Olympics
Sunday's Vanity Fair party was also
where Adam met his celeb crush Shawn
Mendes Adam tweeted the selfie today
writing I planted the seed and I saw the
harvest he is cute he is sweet and the
other guy Shawn Mendes now that seed he
speaks up was this celeb confession
celeb crush confession I should say on
Ellen I was sleeping on Shawn Mendes I'm
sorry
I was sleeping on Shawn Mendes not
literally but I was I didn't realize how
cute he was well here's the thing those
are all good solid choices I would say
I'm going to direct you in the in the in
the direction of some some gay men well
listen Adam is on the market and if you
want a shot at the Olympian thankfully
our girl lauren zima found out the
qualities he's looking for in his dream
guy and I gotta say they're actually
pretty simple these are hot commodities
they know a lot of people have been
trying to slide into the DMZ et cetera
anybody who you would consider going on
a date with should they ask you tonight
and what's your status at this point my
status is single and I mean if you've
got a job and you go to the gym let me
know I guess those standards are I feel
like they could be higher for you you
gotta start somewhere you know you know
I know people have a job and go to the
gym alright that's it guys all right I'm
going to go double down on some meat and
cheese before this vegan thing here
before Adam rip on asked me out so wish
me luck we'll see how long it lasts
we'll be back tomorrow with another
daily Denny so hit that subscribe button
I'll see you guys okay good